hallo zusammen schön guten Abend wir
sind live mit ZDF heute live
Explosionen auf russischen Militärbasen
verursacht durch ukrainische Drohnen und
das auch noch tief im Landesinneren
versteckt dahinter eine neue Taktik
gegen Russland diesen Fragen wollen wir
heute abend nachgehen im Gespräch mit
unserem Reporter in Kiew Hannah
Hebestreit und mit dem
militärökonomen Markus Kolb wenn es
Fragen dazu gibt immer gerne das geht am
besten in den Chats einfach rein posten
oder eine E-Mail schicken an die Adresse
die jetzt gerade eingeblendet wird
vorher aber was genau passiert ist das
hat uns Franziska von tiesenhausen
zusammengefasst
es brennt auf dem Flughafen der
südrussischen Stadt kosk nach einem
mutmaßlichen Drohnenangriff steht am
Morgen ein Öltank in Flammen es ist wohl
der dritte Angriff auf einen russischen
Flugplatz innerhalb von zwei Tagen heute
in kosk gestern meldet Russland
Explosionen auf den
Luftwaffenstützpunkten Engels und ihr
geliwo beide liegen mehr als 500 km von
der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt und von
beiden Stützpunkten starten regelmäßig
strategische langstreckenbombe in
Richtung Ukraine mindestens zwei
Maschinen sollen gestern beschädigt
worden sein ein Vergeltungsschlag
experten gehen davon aus dass solche
aufklärungsdrohnen aus sowjetszeiten für
die Angriffe umfunktioniert wurden
bislang hat sich die Regierungen Kiew
nicht direkt zu den Attacken geäußert es
wäre das erste Mal dass die Ukraine
Ziele so tief im russischen Inland
angreift und würde Russland vor große
Herausforderungen stellen meinen auch
ukrainische Fachleute
er sagt viel aus Russland ist derzeit
nicht in der Lage seinen Luftraum zu
schützen
die neuesten Angriffe zeigen eine
Entwicklung in diesem Krieg deren
Auswirkungen auch Experten noch nicht
voll einschätzen können
und damit begrüße ich Markus Keup
schönen guten Abend guten Abend
wir werden später noch tiefer in die
Analyse einsteigen aber vorab schon mal
die Frage das Besondere an diesen
Attacken ist ja dass sie eben nicht im
Grenzgebiet stattgefunden haben sondern
im Landesinneren wie sehr beunruhigt
dass den Kreml und wie verändert das
diesen Krieg
ja es ist eigentlich eine spektakuläre
Aktion man kann es vielleicht
vergleichen mit der Landung von Matthias
Rust 1987 auf dem Roten Platz in Moskau
auch da wurde ja die sowjetische
Luftabwehr damals völlig überrascht und
heute ist es wieder etwas ähnliches also
wenn Sie denken wenn diese Theorie
stimmt das ist tatsächlich die
tupolew141 ist also ein sowjetisches
System aus den 70er und 80er Jahren da
müsste die russische Luft Abwehr das ja
eigentlich genau kennen und dass dieses
System über mehrere hundert Kilometer
unbemerkt fliegen kann das ist schon
außergewöhnlich wir hatten etwas
Ähnliches zu Beginn des Krieges die
wenigsten werden sich daran erinnern am
10 März war das diesen Jahres der sagt
Vorfall wo genau der gleiche Flugkörper
also auch eine f141 durch die Lufträume
von Rumänien und Ungarn geflogen ist und
dann in der Nähe von
abgestürzt ist und auch damals hat jeder
gesagt in der NATO
wie kann das sein dass unsere
Luftverteidigung das nicht merkt das ist
jetzt eigentlich eine eine ironische
Wendung dass der Flugkörper eben dieses
Mal von westenrost fliegt und nicht von
von Ost nach West aber es ist schon eine
Blamage für die russische Luft abwehren
man muss dazu sagen das sind jetzt keine
kleinen
luftbasen sondern enges ist eine sehr
sehr große Basis auch mit großer
Bedeutung für die strategische Luftwaffe
Russlands und ähm wenn die Ukraine jetzt
demonstrieren kann dass sie diese Ziele
angreifen kann dann ist innerhalb eines
Kreises mit Radius 1000 km um kein
russisches Ziel mehr sicher
so und das sind jetzt natürlich ganz
neue Realitäten für die Russen und für
die Ukraine bedeutet es sie hat jetzt
nicht nur die Initiative im lokalen
kampfrauen in der in der Ukraine selber
sondern wie wir gerade auf der Grafik
sehen sie hat die Initiative im
russischen Luftraum wenn sie jetzt
Russland sind dann stellen Sie sich
jetzt den Problem sie haben mehrere
hundert Ziele die die Ukraine im Prinzip
angreifen kann aber Sie wissen nicht
welches das sind jetzt die neuen
Realitäten für die Russen und da werden
wir auch gleich noch ein Stück weit
tiefer einsteigen vielen Dank für den
Moment und jetzt schalten wir nach Kiew
zu unserem Reporter Herr Hebestreit
hallo Hannah guten Abend
halli hallo nach Mainz kalt bei dir das
ist nicht zu übersehen ich würde ja
gerne die Frage stellen wir haben die
Menschen in der Ukraine auf diese
Nachrichten reagiert das jetzt Ziele in
Russland weit im Landesinneren
attackiert wurden
das hat hier vielen die Herzen sehr
gewärmt die Diskussion wird vor allen
Dingen in den sozialen Medien geführt
und da ist man schon sehr erstaunt das
ist tatsächlich gelungen ist
Ziele mutmaß die muss immer noch sagen
offenbar gelungen ist Ziele auf
russischen Territorium so weit weg von
der Grenze anzugreifen und man ist sehr
erstaunt auch dass Russland nicht in der
Lage ist ein Territorium zu schützen der
Kollege eben hat es ja schon gesagt dass
wir jetzt keine Wald und Wiesen
Flughäfen sondern das sind große das
sind große Militäranlagen die auch einen
hohen Stellenwert im
militärstrategischen Wert haben die
Bomber die da stehen sind unter
Umständen auch Atomwaffen fähig von dort
sind sie auch gestartet mit
konventioneller Munition bestückt und
auf diesen Bildern die man jetzt heute
davon zu sehen bekommen hat war auch
erkennbar das unter einem der
beschädigten Bomber ein Maßstab Körper
befestigt war der offenbar
ein Ziel hatte nämlich hier irgendwo in
der Ukraine
dazu gibt es eine Frage auf Youtube die
ich gerne an Dich weiterreichen würde
warum hat man so wenige Drohnen
gestartet um die Entdeckung zu
erschweren hätte man mehrere geschickt
hätte man auch mehr Schaden anrichten
können
ja das ist jetzt die eine Million Dollar
Frage wenn ich die beantworten könnte
würde ich es gerne tun ich kann mir das
so zusammen reimen die Anzahl dieser
wahrscheinlich modifizierten Drohnen ist
beschränkt und wenn man ganz viele los
schickt und man will ja nicht gleich
Russland den Krieg erklären ne
nun hat Russland ja gestern massive
Angriffe aus der Luft dann geflogen kann
man das als Reaktion verstehen und wie
ist die Lage welche Auswirkungen hatte
das insbesondere auf die Stromversorgung
also wenn man mal das von hinten
aufzäumen hier in Kiew gibt es noch
Strom Kiew wurde nicht stark getroffen
ich hatte die Luftabwehr die ukrainische
Luft Abwehr einiges von Himmel geholt
das kursieren auch Videos im Internet
dass ein deutscher Gepard Panzer
luftabwehrpanzer ein Marschflugkörper
vom Himmel geholt hat das kann man jetzt
nicht genau bewerten ob das ein
authentisches Video ist jedenfalls in
der ukrainische Soldaten drauf zu sehen
die sich sehr freuen und auch sich der
sehr dafür bedanken dass sie dieses
schießgerät aus Deutschland haben
ob das jetzt eine russische Reaktion auf
diesen Drohnen Angriff gestern Morgen
war das glaube ich nicht also mit der
ukrainische militärgeheimnis sagt das
dauert eine Woche 10 Tage bis die Russen
in der Lage sind ihre Ziele zu
definieren und diese Angriffe
vorzubereiten ich gehe eher davon aus
dass die Angriffe vorbereitet waren dann
hat er seit Tagen darauf gewartet heute
z.B ist der Tag der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte das wäre so ein Tag gewesen
wo man sehr stark damit gerechnet hat
vielleicht hat man nun als Reaktion auf
den Angriff einfach nur den ähm die
Attacken um einen Tag nach vorne gezogen
und gesagt jetzt und mein Zeichen der
Stärke liefern ihr startet jetzt und
nicht erst morgen aber das ist alles
das sophisticated gessing die Ukraine
bekennt sich ja nicht direkt zu den
Attacken was steckt dahinter
das hat man bisher ja immer vermieden
ganz klar zu sagen dass man das war es
gab auch schon im Sommer als man auf der
Krim militärflugplätze angegriffen hat
das waren ja so ähnliche Manöver der
hieß es immer na ja die Russen haben
wieder geraucht in der Nähe von Flugzeug
Treibstoff da macht man sich eher
darüber lustig wir haben hier auch
versucht ein offizielle eine
Stellungnahme zu bekommen der hiesigen
Behörden da wird abgewogen und sagt nein
wir sagen dazu nächstes wird ein
bisschen oft auf Twitter geschrieben
aber auch das ist alles nicht worauf man
lesen könnte dass die Uka sagen dass die
Ukraine sagen wir waren das und wir sind
stolz drauf ich glaube da hält man sich
sehr
absichtlich auch bedeckt
aber auch wenn die ukrainische Führung
das jetzt nicht direkt zugibt stellt ja
doch die Frage wie wichtig sind für das
Land solche militärischen Erfolge um
auch einfach mental einigermaßen durch
die nächsten Wochen und Monate zu kommen
das ist sehr sehr wichtig also man sieht
es ja es ist wirklich eisekalt und wir
haben hier in den letzten Wochen mit
sehr vielen Leuten gesprochen die zu
Hause keine keine Heizung haben kein
Strom haben kein Internet haben in
vielen Städten haben sie nicht immer
mehr Wasser und wenn sie Wasser haben
ist es so schlimm Nikolai von Süden
kommt mehr Wasser aus der Leitung was
sind dazu führt dass er allen allen das
Trinkwasser Netz oder die
Wasserversorgung kaputt geht weil das
Meerwasser ist salzig und das macht
alles kaputt also die Leute hier sind
schon ich will nicht sagen in den Knien
aber den lassen schon einiges auf den
Schultern die machen hier schon sehr
viel mit ähm wir hatten das gestern auch
mitbekommen als diese Luftangriff war da
waren wir drei Stunden mit sehr vielen
Menschen im Bunker in der in der U-Bahn
hier in Kiew und wir haben die Leute
gefragt sag mal es geht Euch jetzt so
schlecht und von oben kommen immer
wieder diese diese Raketen ist das jetzt
nicht der anders zu sagen liebe leute
lasst es uns haben Waffenstillstand
probieren durch die Bank alle sagen nee
machen wir nicht wir wollen das jetzt
mal geklärt haben mit Russland und von
dem Hintergrund sind sind solche
Nadelstiche dieses Jahr im Moment auch
sind
sehr gut für die ukrainische Seele
vielen Dank lieber Hannah dass du uns
das so nahe gebracht hast die und dem
Team alles Gute tschüss
und damit wollen wir zurückkommen zu
unserem Militärexperten Markus Keup
kommen wir noch mal im Detail zu diesen
Anschlägen auf die Militärbasen zurück
sie haben es eben schon kurz
angesprochen was könnten das für Drohnen
gewesen sein aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach
ja ich kann mir im Moment nichts anderes
vorstellen als die tupolef141 weil sie
brauchen einen Körper der nicht nur weit
genug sondern auch schnell genug fliegen
kann also wenn Sie die anderen Drohnen
nehmen die die Ukraine ist ja eingesetzt
hat in der Krieg Führung oder auch zum
Beispiel das Reden zwei System die haben
entweder nicht die Reichweite oder nicht
die Geschwindigkeit es würde auch dafür
sprechen dass die Ukraine noch Bestand
hat von diesem System noch als dass wir
solche Zeit ähm ich würde auch nicht
sagen dass man jetzt
erwähnt hat dass die die Anzahl stark
begrenzte sich halte das eher für einen
Demonstrator also für die soll ich sagen
den Nachweis dass die Ukraine diese
Fähigkeit hat ja also sie sie zeigt den
Russen damit quasi an zwei sehr
exponierten Punkten wir können euch
treffen und zwar auch da wo es weh tut
und die Russen haben jetzt diese
Botschaft schon verstanden und jetzt ist
halt die Frage
kann die russische Erde Fans in
absehbarer Zeit auf dieses System
reagieren verstehen Sie sie müssten es
ja eigentlich können weil sie kennen das
System sie haben selber in ihren
Streitkräften wenn sie das nicht können
dann ist der Zustand der russischen
Streitkräfte vielleicht noch schlechter
als wir bisher im Verlauf dieses Krieges
gesehen haben muss man noch mal sagen
diese tupolef m141 ist glaube ich 14
Meter lang mehrere Tonnen schwer und aus
den 70ern da stellt sich ja tatsächlich
die Frage wie kann das sein dass ein
riesen Gerät an der russischen
Luftabwehr vorbeikommt oder wie Hans
Hansen auf Youtube fragt hat Russland
denn keine Luftabwehr
also man muss zunächst dazu sagen es ist
nicht die originale turbolev141 weil die
ist einfach ein passives
aufklärungsgerät also als es
ursprünglich entwickelt wurde das dient
eigentlich dazu dass es in ungefähr 6000
Metern Höhe fliegt und einfach passiv
Radardaten und andere Daten sammelt also
was eine Drohne eben typischerweise
macht die Ukraine haben die aber nun
umgebaut also sprich sie haben sie
zunächst mal versehen mit einem
explosiven Sprengkopf und zweitens haben
sie höchstwahrscheinlich ein GPS
Navigationsgerät eingebaut weil das das
war ja zu der Produktionszeit noch gar
nicht verfügbar weil sie müssen ja
denken sie müssen nicht nur diese
Entfernung überbrücken sie müssen dann
das Ziel auch sehr präzise treffen weil
das Ziel ist ja nicht dass die irgendwo
auf der Airbags wieder geht sondern dass
sie ganz präzise ein Flugzeug trifft
dass sie vorher auf dem Satellitenbild
identifiziert haben mit den genauen
Koordinaten also das ist technisch schon
äh schon eine Herausforderung sowas zu
machen
und wenn sie jetzt fragen
was was hat Russland oder hat Russland
überhaupt eine Luftabwehr ich würde
sagen ja aber wie ich immer sage ein
System zu haben heißt noch lange nicht
dass das System einsatzfähig ist also es
wäre durchaus möglich dass Russland
gesagt hat naja gut uns kann auf unserem
Territorium niemand angreifen es sei
denn vielleicht die strategischen
nuklear Streitkräfte der USA aber sicher
nicht die Ukraine und falls sie das
wirklich geglaubt haben dann haben Sie
jetzt ein großes Problem weil dann
müssen sie jetzt auf sämtlichen
militärischen Zielen die in diesem 1.000
km Kreis liegen den wir da gesehen haben
die müssen sie jetzt alle schnell
nachrüsten und deren er die Fans alle
überprüfen ob die wirklich in der Lage
sind hier effektiven Schutz zu
gewährleisten das ist nicht einfach um
es diplomatisch zu sein
Tamtam spricht auf Facebook noch mal
diesen Vorfall in Kroatien an den See
eingangs erwähnt hatten denn er schreibt
wenn es peinlich für Russland ist es
doch auch peinlich für die NATO Kroatien
oder etwa nicht
ja es war damals am 10 März auch sehr
peinlich für die NATO nur was die NATO
dann sofort gemacht hat schon fünf Tage
später war ein großes Manöver sowohl mit
mit Luft Luft Manövern als auch
luftbodenmanövern wo sie genau diese
diesen Fall simuliert haben und den
abfangen dieser Körper simuliert haben
das heißt da kam eine eine sehr schnelle
response genau weil das so blamabel war
und ähm die Russen müssten jetzt
eigentlich das Gleiche tun wenn sie
halbwegs glaubwürdig sein wollen und ich
denke da das ist so das letzte große
Rätsel dieses Krieges seit Beginn des
Krieges haben sich viele gefragt auch
ich warum greift die strategische
Luftwaffe eigentlich nicht ein weil das
sind über 1200 Flugzeuge die Russland im
Prinzip in der Reserve hat und mit denen
könnten sie ohne weiteres eigentlich
Lufthoheit erlangen haben sie aber nicht
getan man vermutet aus Angst bzw dass
sie dass sie diese Flugzeuge verlieren
könnten bzw weil die Piloten nicht
ausreichend trainiert sind
das heißt wenn sie jetzt sagen Russland
macht ist das gleiche wie die NATO also
große Luft und Luft bodenmanöver dann
müssten sie zunächst mal das
Zusammenspiel dieser beiden
Waffengattungen haben und trainierte
Piloten und wenn das nicht der Fall ist
dann ja dann lässt das Rückschlüsse zu
auf die Einsatzfähigkeit der russischen
Luftwaffe ich denke diese Blamage die
wird für Russland größer werden als für
die NATO damals am 10 märz
kann man noch mal kurz auf die Drohne
zurück es gibt ja auch Berichte dass
auch die Ukraine selbst an einer Drohne
arbeitet wäre das auch eine Theorie dass
die gestern schon zum Einsatz gekommen
sein könnte
halte ich für relativ unwahrscheinlich
also sie müssen ja denken die die
turbolef 1 für 1 hat eine Range von 1000
Kilometern und fliegt mit ungefähr 680
meist Perauer das ist etwas weniger als
Mach 1
das heißt sie brauchen dafür
eine Schubleistung wie sie
typischerweise Flugzeugturbine oder ein
Raketenantrieb liefert also mit normalen
Drohnen ist das eigentlich nicht zu
machen und ich denke wenn wenn die
Ukraine jetzt eigene raketenantriebe
entwickelt hätte und sowas bauen das
wäre wahrscheinlich aufgefallen also
kann ich mir nicht so wirklich
vorstellen
der Reporter in Kiew mit dem wir gerade
gesprochen haben der hat heute
Gelegenheit den ukrainischen
Militärexperten Alexander zu interviewen
und er hat auf die Frage welche
Unterstützung bei dieser Aktion gab
folgendes geantwortet schauen wir uns
kurz sein
ich schließe nicht aus das ist auch auf
dem Territorium Russlands einige Gruppen
geben kann die den Streitkräften
hilfeleisten es können nicht nur
Vertreter der Streitkräfte der Ukraine
oder Bürger der Ukraine sein die
beispielsweise aus den vorübergehend
besetzten Gebieten der Ukraine gewaltsam
auf das Territorium Russlands gebracht
wurden es können die Russen selbst sein
die mit der Ukraine sympathisieren aber
irgendwie ihre Sympathie nicht zeigen
können und helfen wo immer sie können
für Sie wahrscheinlich halten sie das
ja man spekuliert schon länger darüber
dass es einen innerrussischen Widerstand
geben könnte der mit der Ukraine
zusammenarbeitet ich muss dazu sagen das
ist reine Spekulation also man weiß
nicht ob es der Fall ist es gibt
allerdings seit einigen Wochen schon
diese merkwürdige Serie von von Bränden
in Russland also großen feuern sowohl in
zivilen Wohngebäuden in Hochhäusern als
auch bei Gaspipelines man bietet dafür
verschiedene Erklärungen an eines dass
das Ganze Wartungspersonal dass ich
normalerweise um Brandschutz und
Betriebssicherheit kümmert mobilisiert
worden ist und jetzt sich in der Ukraine
befindet und dort noch schlimmer friert
dass ihr Korrespondent ähm aber eine
andere Erklärung ist eben dass es quasi
in russische Widerstandsgruppen gibt
wenn wir mal annehmen das sei der Fall
dann könnte es sein dass ich lokale
Kräfte vor Ort befinden und sozusagen
die Feinsteuerung der Drohne ins Ziel
über Unternehmen das heißt also
sicherstellen dass die Drohne nicht
irgendwo niedergeht sondern genau an dem
Zielpunkt also zum Beispiel genau ein
bestimmtes Flugzeug trifft
das heißt aber auch sie müssten damit
GPS Sendern selber ausgestattet sein was
sie dann in die Gefahr bringt dass sie
selbst gefunden und identifiziert werden
können
es ist schwer zu sagen also es wäre
sicher eine riskante Operation die nicht
einfach von irgendwelchen Leuten
geleitet werden könnte da bräuchten sie
dann Spezialtruppen die dafür
ausgebildet sind und die nach Russland
angeschlossen wurden ich halte es nicht
für unmöglich aber es ist wirklich sehr
spekulativ sowas zu behaupten
tatsächlich haben wir bei heute live
auch schon mal ein Stream zu dem Thema
gemacht ähm inwiefern Sabotage Akte
versuchen Russland zu schwächen aber
kann man jetzt sagen dass das so eine
Art ähm Testballon das ukrainischen
Militärs war und darauf gegebenenfalls
eine neue Kriegsstrategie aufbaut
ich denke es ist mehr als ein Testballon
es ist es ist wirklich eine
Demonstration wozu die Ukraine im
Prinzip in der Lage ist und wie man im
Schach so schön sagt die Drohung ist
stärker als die Ausführung es kommt also
nicht jetzt unbedingt darauf an wie
lange oder wie intensiv könnte die
Ukraine überhaupt zu einem Beschuss
durchführen sondern sie sie zeigt
Russland einfach dass sie dazu in der
Lage ist und das Russland offenbar nicht
in der Lage ist diese diese Flughafen zu
erkennen geschweige denn abzuwehren und
damit verunsichert sie natürlich die
Russen weil die müssen sich jetzt auf
eine andere Form von Kampfführung
einstellen sie dachten bisher der
Konflikt wäre regional in der Ukraine
begrenzt aber verstehen Sie wenn Sie die
Engels treffen können dann können Sie
auch Moskau treffen also jedes beliebige
Ziel in Moskau oder wenn sie nach Süden
schauen dieser Kreis der geht ja bis an
die türkische Nordküste also das
Schwarzen Meeres ja und jetzt ist er die
Frage wenn das wirklich so ist dann
müssten sie eigentlich ihre gesamten
militärischen Dispositionen
umorganisieren und das das schafft viel
Unsicherheit in der militärischen
Planung ich denke deswegen hat Putin
auch den Nationalen Sicherheitsrat
einberufen weil weil er wirklich
komplett konfus ist und die Leute nicht
wissen wie sie damit umgehen sollen also
verstehen sie selbst wenn das jetzt
militärisch keinen großen Wert hat der
psychologische Effekt der wird sicher
bleiben
und damit haben sie auch
freundlicherweise schon die Frage von
Jannis Müller auf Youtube beantwortet
der gefragt hat wie gefährdet für
Drohnen Angriffe moskau ist aus der
anderen Perspektive wie hoch ist das
Risiko dass die Ukraine dann damit fährt
oder anders gefragt von rafix werden
diese Angriffe zu einer weiteren
Eskalation von Russland Seite führen wir
könnten eine Reaktion Russlands aussehen
ja gut also wie könnte eine Reaktion
Aussehen ist es ist schwer vorstellbar
was die Russen in diesem Krieg
eigentlich noch noch aktivieren wollen
also was was nun passiert von Seiten der
Ukraine ist einfach zu sagen okay die
militärischen Effektoren die unsere
zivile Infrastruktur unsere
Energieversorgung in Schutt und Asche
schießen die nehmen wir jetzt selber
raus und diese Effektoren die befinden
sich zum Beispiel auf diesen beiden
Airbase die jetzt angegriffen worden
sind also die Messers die auf die
Ukraine abgeschlossen werden und dann
dazu führen dass es dort keinen Strom
kann Wasser und so weiter gibt die
befinden sich zum Beispiel auf diesen
tupolef Langstrecken sondern also die
werden an die dran montiert und dann aus
der Luft tief aus dem russischen
Mutterland abgeschlossen und fliegen
dann bis in die Ukraine hinein das heißt
die sind ein legitimes militärisches
Ziel so dass die Ukraine sagen kann die
nehmen wir raus um diese Bedrohung zu
neutralisieren was können die Russen
dagegen tun naja sie können Ihre Erde
Fans versuchen aufzustocken sie könnten
versuchen noch mehr von diesen
Terrorangriffen durchzuführen das ist
aber nicht wirklich mehr
erfolgversprechend also die Ukraine ist
mittlerweile recht gut darin ungefähr
85% dieser Raketen und und Messer als
abzufangen und und weitere Eskalation
halte ich für unwahrscheinlich ist es
gibt jetzt sicher wieder irgendwelche
Scharlatane die vom dritten Weltkrieg
und der nuklear Krieg reden und so
weiter ich sage da das gleiche was ich
schon Monate lang sage man hat den
Russen sehr klar gemacht was passiert
wenn sie auch nur daran denken und wenn
Sie jetzt das beide das mal
zusammenzählen also sprich Russland
fängt wieder an mit dem nuklearen Säbel
zu lassen hat aber gleichzeitig eine
Erde Fans die nicht mal lautetech
Drohnen aus den 70ern und 80ern erkennen
kann dann können Sie sich vorstellen was
dann bei einem massiven NATO Luftschlag
passieren würde im Falle von von Atomen
ja also für Russland ist das ein
größeres Problem als so mancher jetzt
vielleicht am
wenn Sie das Thema NATO noch mal
ansprechen dann muss man vielleicht
können sie noch mal erklären dass
Attacken auf Russland ja in dem Moment
absolut heikel werden würden wenn Waffen
aus dem Westen verwendet würden korrekt
ja man muss allerdings sagen das ist ja
bei diesen Attacken nicht der Fall
sondern Russland und die Ukraine
befinden sich im Kriegszustand auch wenn
Russland sein Angriffskrieg ja niemals
offen deklariert hat aber eben wenn wir
annehmen das ist tatsächlich die Zukunft
141 gewesen ist dann ist das überhaupt
keine Frage natürlich wenn sie jetzt
irgendwelche westlichen Waffensysteme
oder NATO Material dafür verwendet
hätten dann wäre das sicher eine
kritische Frage gewesen aber so muss man
sagen nein das ist immer noch Teil des
regionalen Konfliktes zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine und man muss auch ganz
klar sagen bevor jetzt die
Verschwörungstheoretiker wieder kommen
es ist die Ukraine die sich verteidigt
das souveräne Nation und um ihren
Fortbestand als Staat und übrigens auch
das Überleben des eigenen Volkes hier
kämpft und und nicht irgendein
sogenannter Stellvertreterkrieg wie er
gewisse Personen das in der
Vergangenheit versucht haben
darzustellen
Maurice möchte noch mal wissen ob es der
Ukraine auf diesem Weg gelingen kann
nachhaltigen Schaden in der Versorgung
der russischen Soldaten zu verursachen
ja im Prinzip schon wenn sie eben das
gleiche jetzt mit den Tupolew machen
würde wie das was sie mit den
heimat-systemen schon lange macht die
heimat-systeme die kennen wir ja
mittlerweile alle haben eine Reichweite
von 70 bis 80 km maximal und die dienen
ja im Moment dazu die russische Logistik
hinter der Front möglichst zu
beschädigen also sprich Eisenbahnlinien
ähm
Munitionsdepots Treibstofflager und so
herauszunehmen aber eben nur im
regionalen Kontext jetzt könnte man sich
natürlich vorstellen dass man das ganze
mit den jetzt auch in größere Maßstab
nach Russland hineinträgt also dass man
zum Beispiel Eisenbahnknoten auch in
Russland ausschaltet oder größere
Tanklager dort das ist bisher schon
passiert also in beldor z.B gab es mal
dann angegriff auf den größeres
Handlager aber innerhalb dieses riesigen
Radius könnten Sie natürlich auch große
Schäden anrichten in der russischen
Militär Logistik
und dann gibt es auch noch die Frage
nach den Zivilisten die ist natürlich
auch in Russland gibt wie groß ist die
Gefahr für die bei den Drohnenangriffen
ich würde sagen die ist nicht so groß
sofern sie nur militärische Ziele
treffen ich denke das ist auch der
Unterschied zwischen der
verbrecherischen russischen
Kriegsführung die ja ganz bewusst auf
zivile Ziele schießt also die nicht nur
zivile Opfer als Kollateralschaden in
Kauf nimmt sondern ganz bewusst
Zivilisten und die zivile Infrastruktur
angreifen
das muss die Ukraine aber nicht tun
sofern sie nur militärische Ziele
angreift und ich betone Eisenbahnlinien
sofern auf diesen Eisenbahnen
militärische Güter transportiert werden
und ebenso Treibstoff Lager sind
militärische Ziele dann kann sie die
angreifen aber Zivilisten werden dadurch
zunächst mal nicht betroffen sein die
russischen Soldaten die werden dann
natürlich mit drauf gehen aber das ist
nun mal die Natur des Krieges
und noch eine Frage von Jumpy welche
Rolle spielt in diesem Zusammenhang die
Angst vor der Ausweitung der Krise wäre
es nicht möglich dass eine konsequente
Unterstützung jetzt der Ukraine den
Krieg verkürzen würde
ja auf jeden Fall also man muss ja ganz
klar sehen das was Putin angesichts der
der grauenhaften Performance seiner
Armee dringend braucht ist ein
Waffenstillstand und genau den darf man
ihm nicht geben sondern je mehr die
Ukraine in die Lage versetzt jetzt die
russische Aggression zu neutralisieren
das heißt die Russen zurückzudrängen und
letztlich hinauszudrängen aus der
Ukraine desto schneller ist dieser Krieg
auch vorbei wir erinnern uns die große
Vorbedingung für Friedensverhandlungen
ist der Abzug oder der Hinauswurf aller
russischen Truppen aus der Ukraine wenn
sie nicht freiwillig gehen dann wird man
sie mit Gewalt hinausbringen und je
schneller man das tun kann desto eher
ist der Krieg vorbei
sie haben zwar eben schon über den
unwahrscheinlichen Einsatz von
Atomwaffen gesprochen also wir merken im
Chat beschäftigt dass die Menschen doch
immer wieder sehr deshalb will ich die
Frage noch mal weitergeben an sie
blexomatra fragt auf Youtube könnte
Russland dies als eine Legitimation zum
Einsatz von Kernwaffen nutzen
ja also ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt dass
sie nicht so dumm sind das zu tun also
man hat Russland klar gemacht sowohl von
Seiten der Amerikaner als auch übrigens
von Seiten Chinas falls ihr auch nur
daran denkt dass zu tun dann wird ein
solcher Schlag gegen das russische
Militär einsetzen dass das zu nichts
mehr in der Lage sein wird ja und wir
sollten immer dran denken der Einsatz
von Atomwaffen bedingt zunächst mal die
nuklearde das heißt also insbesondere
auch in Einsatz der strategischen
Luftwaffe zum Transport der atomköpfe
und die würde man natürlich als erstes
rausnehmen genauso wie die U-Bahn die
U-Boot Waffe und die landgestützten
Systeme man muss auch ich sage das immer
wieder man muss als erstes die nukleare
Bereitschaft Russlands anschauen wir
sehen seit Monaten keine Veränderung der
Luke an Bereitschaft also z.B dass man
auch nur die Atom strengköpfe
zusammenführen würde mit den
Trägersystems überhaupt nicht der Fall
und ich sage auch was immer wieder die
Atomwaffe ist nicht der eigentlich
nuklear-sprengkopf die Waffe ist die
Angst des Westens davor das ist also vor
allem in Deutschland sehr sehr stark
verbreitet ja dass das die Leute
sich davor fürchten ich ich würde da
doch etwas zu zur Besonnenheit raten das
ist das letzte was ich in diesem
Konflikt erwarten würde okay also das
Schließen sie aus trotz allem hat
Präsident Putin haben Sie auch schon
gesagt der seinen Sicherheitsrat
einberufen und sein Sprecher sagte man
wolle alle notwendigen Maßnahmen
ergreifen um Russland zu schützen letzte
Frage an Sie wovon gehen Sie aus was
kommt da
ja was kommt da ich würde sagen es ist
wird vielleicht irgendein
vergeltungsversuch wieder kommen also so
ähnlich wie nach der Brücke von kerbt
dass er auch eine riesige Blamage war
für die Russen also vielleicht werden
Sie jetzt die nächste Woche wieder
irgendeine Aktion durchführen da sehen
wir gerade die Bilder genau BAM ja und
und eben versuchen wieder so ein
massiven Schlag durchzuführen wie sich
die letzten Wochen getan haben ich ich
denke nicht dass das noch große
Resultate haben wird man muss auch sehen
dass das Depot der der Russland noch zur
Verfügung hat also insbesondere die KH
55 und kh101 dass die sich langsam
Lehren das heißt also wenn da jetzt
nicht wirklich noch so ein ein größerer
Schlag kommen sollte in den nächsten
zehn Tagen und dann sagt uns das auch
sehr viel darüber was Russland überhaupt
noch tun kann
und damit haben sie auch indirekt die
Frage von Markus Kunert beantwortet ob
man für den kommenden Winter noch große
militärische Vorhaben beider Seiten
erwarten kann ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für Ihre Einschätzung und für
ihre Analysen machen sie es gut bis bald
tschüss gerne schönen Abend noch danke
schön ja und damit möchte ich mich auch
ganz herzlich von Ihnen und Euch
verabschieden mit einem Kommentar von
stunning ride auf Youtube der uns
schreibt der frierende Korrespondenz
soll sich mal von uns warm in den Arm
genommen fühlen wir geben es an Hannah
Hebestreit gerne weiter vielen Dank und
bis bald tschüss